[Música]
el ejército de Israel mató a tres
jóvenes palestinos en cisjordania
ocupada en el año más mortífero para los
palestinos de los territorios ocupados y
en el día internacional de solidaridad
con el pueblo palestino cuando se
cumplen 75 años de la resolución de la
ONU que contemplaba la creación de un
estado judío y un estado árabe en
Palestina
jornada cargada de diplomacia en torno a
la guerra en Ucrania dos cumbres de alto
nivel debaten la invasión rusa reunida
en Rumanía la otan mantiene su apoyo a
kiev y en Alemania miembros del g7
condenan los crímenes de guerra en
territorio ucraniano
la Cumbre de la alianza del Pacífico se
hará en Lima así lo confirmó el
presidente chileno Gabriel borich una
medida de solidaridad con el jefe de
estado peruano Pedro Castillo aquí en el
congreso de Perú le impidió viajar a
México donde estaba previsto el
encuentro
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
hoy 29 de noviembre se conmemora el día
internacional de solidaridad con el
pueblo de Palestina hace 75 años la
asamblea general de la ONU aprobó la
resolución que estipulaba la creación de
un estado judío y un estado árabe en
Palestina El Aniversario llega en un
momento de recrudecimiento del conflicto
derivado de la ocupación israelí
Un día como hoy pero en 1947 con la
herida del holocausto aún abierta
Naciones Unidas tomó una decisión
histórica el plan de partición de
Palestina en un estado judío y un estado
árabe
la resolución del comité sobre Palestina
fue adoptada por 33 votos 13 en contra y
10 abstenciones
una medida que israelíes apoyaron y los
árabes rechazaron por algo que ya
preveían hace 75 años que se estado
árabe nunca llegaría y que creían
Injusto ya que a pesar de representar un
tercio de la población el plan les daba
a los judíos casi la mitad del
territorio algo que desencadenó en uno
de los conflictos más largos de nuestros
tiempos la creación del estado de Israel
y su primera guerra con Palestina con
enfrentamientos a miles de muertes y El
Éxodo de cerca de 700.000 palestinos que
siguen hasta día de hoy sin ir más lejos
Este martes tres jóvenes murieron a
manos del ejército de israelí cerca de
ramala y hebrón sumándose a los cerca de
150 palestinos muertos en lo que va de
año la historia
Esto es una prueba de que la arrogancia
de la ocupación no distingue entre
estudiantes o ancianos no hay respeto
por la humanidad
una situación es que el actual
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez tacha de insostenible
insto a todas las partes a tomar medidas
inmediatas para reducir las tensiones y
poner fin a la espiral de violencia que
envuelve a la cisjordania ocupada en
este día de Palestina reafirmemos
nuestro apoyo al pueblo palestino en su
búsqueda para construir un futuro de paz
justicia seguridad y dignidad para todos
y es que ese prometido estado palestino
está más lejos de hacerse realidad que
nunca con cada vez más pérdida de
territorio desde 1947 algunas ong temen
que incluso termine totalmente
anexionado por Israel todo en el medio
de las demandas de una investigación
independiente sobre la ocupación a la
que Israel se niega hoy dos cumbres de
alto nivel se centraron en la invasión
rusa de Ucrania por un lado la Cumbre de
los ministros de exteriores de países
miembros de la otan en bucarest Rumanía
ha girado en torno al envío a kiev de
más ayuda militar y de asistencia para
reconstruir la infraestructura devastada
por otro lado los ministros Justicia del
g7 se encontraron en Alemania algunos de
los miembros del grupo de las siete
potencias mundiales entre las que se
cuenta también Rusia condenaron los
crímenes de guerra cometidos en Ucrania
los criminales de guerra no deben y no
pueden sentirse seguros En ningún lugar
donde podamos detenerlos los llevaremos
a juicio en estricto cumplimiento del
principio de juicio justo ningún crimen
de guerra debe quedar impune Ese es el
mensaje de hoy
y nuestra enviada especial en Ucrania
Catalina Gómez Ángel se encuentra al
norte de kiev cerca de la frontera con
belarús una zona que estuvo bajo control
de las tropas rusas a principio de la
invasión
Esta es una pequeña población campesina
de las miles que hay repartidas por toda
Ucrania es tan especial está en el norte
de la ciudad de kiefa una hora y media y
muy cerca también a la frontera con
viola a Rusia de hecho esto fue una de
las primeras poblaciones que cayó en
control de las fuerzas rusas durante la
invasión el 24 de febrero ellos
estuvieron aquí hasta que se retiraron
de esta parte del norte de Ucrania y
ellos nos cuentan que aquí ya vivieron
en ese momento un invierno un final de
invierno este año bastante duro porque
cuando estaban los rusos aquí cortaron
la electricidad y ahora vuelven a vivir
algo parecido no tienen luz en sus casas
va y viene pero prácticamente no la
tienen pero logran calentarse con unas
calefacciones de madera a lo que ellos
están acostumbrados y dicen que viene
mal Ellos están acostumbrados a pasar
inviernos bastante duro y que tienen las
la manera para para hacerlo y por esta
razón en algunas comunidades de hecho
también al gobierno ucraniano ha
invitado a residentes de áreas urbanas a
moverse a poblaciones como estas para
quitarle presión a la capacidad
eléctrica de las grandes ciudades en esa
crisis que tienen energética y que están
esperando nuevos ataques también de las
fuerzas rusas lo que hará que este sea
tal vez el peor invierno para los
ucranianos especialmente en las ciudades
que no están acostumbradas
y durante dos semanas las fuerzas
iraníes han atacado a los grupos de la
oposición kurda iraní con sede en Irak
Teherán acusa a estos grupos de
orquestar las protestas masivas
desatadas por la muerte de Mac
la ciudad de coya está en calma pero La
amenaza nunca está lejos Irán ataca
regularmente la base del partido
democrático del kurdistán iraní estos
ataques han matado a varios civiles
incluida la esposa embarazada de este
pez merga combatiente armado kurdo
estaba lejos de la base pero
bombardearon justo en medio del
campamento eran viviendas donde vivían
mujeres y niños no estaban armados ni
eran militares herido el mismo en el
ataque se encuentra en un lugar que
quiere mantener en secreto tras el
último ataque de hace una semana los
familiares de los pez mergas se
dispersaron surux de 7 años vivía en el
campamento a menudo dibuja el ataque a
su escuela que fue atacada a finales de
septiembre
Aquí están los misiles que bombardearon
nuestra escuela un misil destrozó
nuestra escuela y los alumnos huyeron no
hay nadie allí desde el ataque no tuve
miedo no soy un niño que tenga miedo
los ataques iraníes no solo afectan a
los civiles vinculados a los grupos
armados el pueblo de armota albergaba a
250 familias casi todas han huido este
domingo los bancos de la Iglesia
Católica permanecieron vacíos y ya no se
celebraron servicios
le gustaría que la situación se
resolviera Y que todos los actores
externos o internos respetarán a esta
nación como a todas las demás en todo el
kurdistán iraquí el exasperaciones
similar en el valle de nala aquí el
partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán el pkk se enfrenta al ejército
Turco según los informes 15 civiles han
muerto a causa de los ataques aéreos
turcos desde principios de año en el
kurdistán iraquí
se trata de un enfrentamiento entre el
pkk y Turquía en la región Así que
podemos decir que Turquía y el pkk son
responsables pero el gobierno debe
expulsarlos de esta zona
los pastores ya no pueden cuidar
libremente su ganado en las montañas los
habitantes de aquí se sienten aislados y
abandonados por las autoridades iraquíes
y kurdas
finalmente la Cumbre de la alianza del
Pacífico se celebrará en Lima una medida
de apoyo de los miembros de la alianza a
Pedro Castillo recordemos que el
congreso de Perú impidió al mandatario
peruano viajar a México donde estaba
previsto inicialmente el encuentro el
movimiento llega en un momento en que
por primera vez los jefes de estado de
los cuatro países de la alianza López
Obrador en México Petro en Colombia
borich en chile y Castillo en Perú están
alineados a la izquierda el anuncio lo
ha comunicado borich en el marco de su
encuentro con Castillo para celebrar los
200 años de relaciones diplomáticas
entre lima y Santiago y reforzar la
cooperación en temas de migración y
crimen organizado
hemos concordado con el presidente de
Castillo realizar la reunión suspendida
de los presidentes de la alianza del
Pacífico es decir Perú Chile Colombia
México
en
el país del Perú en una fecha que
daremos a conocer prontamente una vez
hayamos terminado las consultas con los
otros países miembros de la alianza
gracias por su atención sigan con
nosotros
[Música]